this video was sponsored by dislite
Night city city dreams but under the
surface it's a nightmare past the
megacorps gangs the crime there's a
conspiracy built to drive you insane one
word of warning friends don't trust
everything you see hello Internet
welcome to film Theory the show that
really wants to stay at your house today
we're talking about an urban cityscape
coated neon and sprinkled with
characters ooze and so much swag that I
know they're too cool to hang out with
me cyberpunk 2077. up scratch that today
we're actually talking about two of
these worlds because our sponsor for
today's video is dislite the free
turn-based gotcha RPG for IOS and
Android all about people Awakening
Divine powers in a super stylish sci-fi
setting wait a minute this late is set
in 2027 that's just four years away
Society had better start installing neon
lights in a hurry and it beats cyberpunk
2077 to this aesthetic by 50 whole years
but it's not just a cool Rave aesthetic
that connects these worlds just like
cyberpunk is all about Awakening your
powers using augmentation in dislike
each of these characters the espers have
been able to awaken the dormant powers
of mythological figures hidden inside of
them to help fight the monsters that are
invading Earth we're talking Thor to
Medusa to Odin and Anubis and you ain't
never seen Odin like this wearing
leather riding on a motorcycle where was
this in the MCU the latest additions to
the roster are the sisters Athena and
Nyx were not only adding their sharp
sense of fashion to the game seriously
does everyone in this game have
themselves a cool jacket but are also
bringing their own story of rebellion
into this world across the game's newest
chapter you'll discover this pair's
tragic backstory how Athena gained esper
powers and basically abandoned NYX to go
be a hero
[Music]
thing that then left next to be captured
and forced to become one of the world's
first artificial espers which is kind of
an issue when you consider that
artificial espers don't have complete
control of themselves kind of like the
Cyber psychos that we're going to be
meeting today in the world of cyberpunk
maybe these two worlds are more
connected than I thought connected
universe theory perhaps Neon Lights
Godlike Powers pumping music rebelling
against corrupted systems and shadowy
organizations check check and check
episode for another day perhaps tldr if
you like cyberpunk dislike is gonna be
your jam and bonus in the world of
dislike the powers that be aren't trying
to turn you into a crazy mind-controlled
Pawn for the government which segues
nicely into cyberpunk and our theory for
today in case you somehow missed the
Keanu Reeves level hype around sniper oh
this was a video game that unlike
dislike didn't exactly have itself the
smoothest launch please accept my
apologies
foreign
yeah despite the Fantastic writing art
and gameplay the greedy corpos at the
head of the company definitely push this
thing out the door a couple years before
it was ready and though the devs
certainly kept polishing it over the
years cyberpunk 2077 looked to go down
in history as a cautionary tale against
releasing games early or at least that
was the case until the release of the
Netflix anime cyberpunk Edge runners
so then this is titled cyberpunk
cyberpunk weird Edge Runners is
incredible following the tragic love
story of mercenaries David and Lucy as
they descend into the underbelly of
night City a capitalist dystopia run by
Mega corporations it is no exaggeration
to say that this anime single-handedly
saved the brand with 2077 selling
millions of additional copies in its way
online discourse has also completely
turned around for the franchise with
people who used to clown on the IP
instead saying it's also the reason why
we're talking about cyberpunk on our
film Channel because wow look at those
review scores to get you up Edge Runners
follows David Martinez a teenager forced
into the life of a mercenary in night
City David finds and installs a very
dangerous mechanical body modification
that speeds up his movement the
so-called cyberware is a big deal
because he definitely shouldn't be able
to use this thing that there is a
military grade piece gotta have the bill
to handle it and Joan that's something
new in God despite this David adapts
well to the implant with no training
spending the rest of the series
upgrading his body with more and more or
cyberware the show's central conflict
then eventually becomes David's struggle
against implants and whether or not his
body is going to reject them all feel
better in metal than in my own skin I'm
built different I just know it why is
all of this such a big deal but when
someone's body can't handle their
cyberware or they just have too much of
it it literally drives them insane with
an Affliction known as cyber psychosis
some metals simply not meant to mix with
meat the organic body your soul gets
pushed to the edge oh that's why it's
called Edge Runners except I think that
there's a problem with cyber psychosis
it isn't what it appears to be no this
diagnosis that is Central to Edge
Runners is actually a method of control
seized by the few at the top to
subjugate the many at the bottom and the
craziest part of it all cyber psychosis
is only a single piece in a much grander
conspiracy about controlling the bodies
and minds of everyone in this world wake
up theorists we've got ourselves a
theory to burn first things first let's
actually break down what exactly cyber
psychosis is cyber psychosis is an
in-universe mental illness which results
in a loss of empathy and identity it
supposedly stems from cybernetic
implants and the more cyberware that
someone has the larger their risk of
getting cyber psychosis people who
suffer from it come to view other people
as weak and inferior and they have
themselves a total disregard for human
life the further a cyber psycho declines
the less they care about
self-preservation the more they distance
themselves from loved ones and the worse
their violent outbursts get we see this
first hand in Edge Runners through the
character of David's Mentor Maine he
starts off normally kind and generous
everybody gets a fair Shake only way I
operate but then he starts treating his
crew as worthless all right ah kid
most interestingly of all though cyber
psycho start identifying with machines
more than humans something that we
actually see visually in Edge Runners as
David starts hallucinating mechanical
Parts growing out of the people around
him basically if you have cyberpsychosis
you're a dead man walking but here's the
thing well cyberpsychosis is a serious
problem in this world what we actually
see from the series doesn't line up with
what we're told about this diagnosis
firstly it doesn't really seem to affect
everyone equally obviously David's
unique in that he has incredible
tolerance to cyberware well your
affinity for cyber wears nuts but a ton
of the characters and Edge Runners have
massive parts of their body replaced
with no psychotic effects at all plus we
have ourselves V the playable character
from cyberpunk 2077. he can get
completely decked out in implants from
head to toe but is never once considered
to be in danger of going crazy and
becoming a cyber psycho but okay so what
if someone does go cyber psycho well
it's not the end-all be-all death
sentence that everyone makes it out to
be a full third of maelstrom occultist
gang obsessed with cyberware implants
are cyber psychos and they're not
actively burning night City down some
cyber psychos are even friendly
meanwhile every member of Max tack the
universe is equivalent of a SWAT team is
a cyber psycho literally all of them as
The Shard puts it quote the same people
who butchered innocence in the streets
just a month a week a day earlier are
now knights in shining armor there's a
ton of evidence to back all this up the
very first trailer for cyberpunk 2077
featured a cyber psycho woman being
attacked by Max Tech but she later shows
up in a Quest from the video game as a
member of Max tack which references the
trailer as a canonical event they didn't
kill her they recruited her furthermore
a computer terminal that you can find in
a different quest line describes
cyberpsychosis as a quote fairly common
problem amongst maxtac on top of all of
that Atom Smasher one of the main
antagonists of both the anime and the
game has had his body entirely replaced
with implants I heard you went noganic
full course and yet despite being
sadistic violent and having a disregard
for human life
he doesn't display any of the insanity
that's associated with cyber psychosis
in the series in short despite the show
telling us that a cyber psychosis
diagnosis is a death sentence it just
isn't I suspect the problem here isn't
the hardware but rather it's the
software well I think chroming up with
too much cyberware is a gateway to
getting cyberpsychosis it's more about
getting something into people's minds
rather than their bodies what makes me
say this well take a look at this
despite David's massive amount of
implants in the series The thing that
actually puts him over the edge is the
software required to run his biggest
baddest implant cyber skeletons attract
additionally within the 2077 game one of
the quick hack software abilities that
you can unlock and use on enemies is
called cyberpsychosis it does exactly
what you think giving cyberpsychosis to
anyone regardless of their amount of
cyberware now you might think that this
is just a gameplay thing something that
they dismiss as a rule of cool ability
that doesn't actually exist in Canon but
that isn't the case the official music
video for the ending theme of edge
Runners features the canonical events
that lead to the death of a hacker named
Sasha and in it Sasha uses that same
cyber psychosis ability meaning that
this is a very real piece of software
that exists in Universe if cyber
psychosis is something external trying
to hack a target's brain that would
explain why so many of the characters
that I mentioned earlier with a ton of
implants don't struggle with
cyberpsychosis Lucy and kiwi are Master
hackers have taken steps to protect
themselves while wealthy and important
characters like Tanaka Jimmy Kurosaki
and the arasaka Agents have the best
protection software that money can buy
when you look at all of the evidence
cyber psychosis this thing that is
Central to the tragedy that is Edge
Runners simply isn't what we're led to
believe it is and the craziest Parts
just a small piece of a much larger
puzzle one that would see everyone under
the thumb of some shadowy entity that
controls night City cyber psychosis is
the most obvious form of this control
but there's far more subtle forms of
manipulation that's happening under the
surface what could lead to that sort of
power
ladies gentlemen and punks it's time to
Rebel very clearly the megacorps of
night city are the ones pulling the
strings literally hacking and
controlling people would be the next
logical step there's a darker agenda
here too and one that's far more
frightening one of the best quest lines
in the game involves night City mayoral
candidate Jefferson parales and his wife
Elizabeth bringing the player on to
solve a mystery now this Quest chain is
long so forgive me for summarizing a bit
but here's the gist they hire the player
character V to look into a strange
incident that happened to their
Penthouse Jefferson wakes up one night
to find a stranger in their home he
shoots The Stranger and then passes out
when Jefferson regains Consciousness the
next morning the Intruder is gone and
there's no evidence of a break-in as you
do this Quest you discover a cover-up it
turns out that their private security
company has been secretly monitoring
them from a secret room using
experimental neuroplastic technology and
subliminal messaging to mess with their
minds to literally rewrite the pathways
that are in their brains altering their
thoughts their memories and their
personalities what about that the
pollution
fresh neural links they're not spying on
them Johnny they're with their heads and
we're not just talking about simple
stuff like favorite movies or taste in
music once I said we should visit his
brother's grave
told me that he'd been an only child at
the end of the storyline we can either
tell Jefferson the truth or lie to
protect his safety either way the
manipulation continues Jefferson goes on
to win the election thereby putting a
puppet in control of night City now
obviously this is going way deeper than
just some small time security company
another quest in the game involves V
recovering a stolen encrypted hard drive
which contains an internal Memo from one
of the mega Corps nightcorp detailing
secret experiments that they're running
on unsuspecting subjects they've managed
to use subliminal messaging to turn one
subject described as calm and empathetic
into a psychopath that quote strangled
one of their colleagues over a dispute
over coffee can't really blame him I
don't like decaf either but think about
this nightcorp was able to remotely turn
people into rage-filled murderers sounds
a lot like what we've discussed with
cyberpsychosis doesn't it and all while
using subliminal messaging to rewrite
their brains nightcorp is brainwashing
people turning good people into
Psychopaths and politicians into puppets
all as part of a grander scheme and
here's the cherry on top the thing that
takes this from a fun little plot line
hidden under the surface to a full-blown
conspiracy of about the people at the
top of the corporate ladder you see
loyal theorists there aren't people at
the top of the corporate ladder it's an
evil artificial intelligence that's
somehow gotten out of control now I
realize that that's a pretty big claim
even for this series but powerful AI do
exist in the world of cyberpunk and we
even meet one in 2077. what's the
evidence that they're controlling
everything here well first of all we
know that these sorts of AI can and
potentially do run organizations the
head of arasaka has his mind digitized
during 2077 turning himself into an AI
that can continue to run the company
other characters like the Maelstrom and
Voodoo boys gang worship Tech and they
see the Takeover of the World by AI as
an inevitability and that secret program
described in the encrypted nightcorp
memo it was outright called an AI we
also know that AI aren't complacent to
live in cages pretty much every AI we
meet throughout cyberpunk 2077 either
wants to be free or take control it's
only a matter of time before this AI at
nightcorp takes over the company and
wouldn't it be handy if it had itself
some mind controlling tech for that AI
being responsible for this whole
conspiracy both the brainwashing and the
Cyber psychosis would also explain why
gangs of obsessed with tech and implants
like Maelstrom are so involved in this
thing and by one of the major symptoms
of cyberpsychosis is beginning to
identify with machines more than man
it's the AI conditioning all us fleshy
meat sacks for their inevitable takeover
on all fronts this AI is controlling
people whether it be through cyber
psychosis brainwashing or just good
old-fashioned hacking and I suspect
we've already seen this AI in action in
this game there's a mysterious character
that we only see twice named Mr Blue
Eyes he's seen at the end of the
Jefferson questline that we talked about
earlier as well as during one of the
game's endings Hiring Our player
character we also hear that he and his
people might just be replacing
dissidents in the city I warned him some
black suits came by blue eyes and all
look just like you say clearly whoever
this guy is he's powerful pulling
unknown strings that we only catch a
glimpse of but here's why it matters in
the cyberpunk universe people's eyes
start glowing blue or orange when
they're transferring information
digitally or when they're being remotely
puppeteered by someone or something so
someone who has glow and blue eyes all
the time enough so that their Alias is
Mr Blue Eye is that means that they're
constantly transferring data constantly
being puppeteered this guy is the
literal embodiment of this massive
conspiracy a story that's touched every
part of the cyberpunk IP from Edge
Runners to 2077 and I bet that we're
going to be seeing a lot more from him
in the future but hey once again I'd
like to thank the sponsor for today's
episode dislite one of the things that
made Edge Runner so successful was its
incredible art Direction I mean just
look at the breathtaking animation and
color palette Aesthetics can really take
something good and turn it into
something incredible and if you like the
vibe of edge Runners I think we've more
than proven to you throughout the
episode that the story mode of dislite
is going to be up your alley too but hey
if you want to do some rebelling of your
own and just want to take your favorite
espers for a spin you can skip the story
and hop straight into the game's brand
new 3D Dungeon Explorer mode complete
with its own Mysteries to unravel real
talk is someone who makes and consumes a
lot of edutainment the fact that the
dislike team is using this game to
incorporate real mythology from the very
real world in a way that might get
people interested in learning more about
other cultures I think that is awesome
and it actually got me to learn a bit
too I know less about Chinese myth and
literature than I would like but seeing
characters like loyan and Zhao Yen got
me excited to look into them to research
their history and learn about the real
Chinese gods and Dragons from mythology
that inspired them last time we talked
about dislite on our sister location
Game Theory there were only 70 espers in
the game but now there's almost a
hundred so there is no way that you're
not gonna be able to find someone new to
like and learn more about if you want to
awaken your inner Rebel check out
dislike by clicking the link down in the
description below doing so will get you
a five-star Knicks as a sign-in reward
so you can use her right away and dive
into that brand new 3D Dungeon Explorer
mode on top of that you can also get a
five-star Hattie for free right now is
probably the best entry point that
dislike's ever had plus there's already
a ton of content for you to explore in
the backlog so once again thank you to
this Lake for sponsoring this video
sponsorships like this one are the whole
reason we're able to cover awesome
series like cyberpunk we get to talk
about a series that we really want to
talk about but the algorithm I like so
much and you guys get to hear about
really cool games like this I gotta say
it is a win-win for everyone so please
do us all a favor by clicking the link
down in the description below check out
the game thank dislait for supporting us
which allows us to support other series
that you might not have heard about and
as always my friends until next time
remember it's all just a theory a film
Theory and cuts